okay for those joining this livestream I
believe this is the 99th one of these
live streams of our internal software
design reviews we are continuing here to
talk about food all right where should
we start
so the one thing that we did last time
didn't finish reverie when did you ever
use what is the right balance between
two computers and natural language on
how to make the input interpretation for
foods right okay and you've got a bunch
of examples here which is good bunch of
examples and bunch of different
possibilities until prepared foods one
item is particularly ugly one serving of
I mean the word foods there is pretty
weird it's more relevant before you have
the one serving of diversion burgers is
suppressed and downplayed okay all right
so oh my gosh we have versions aid
through P yes and not all of them are
alive a lot of them have a lot of
duplicate stuff in them so I've closed
up some sections that we're where there
are duplicates and that sort of thing
but the point is others lots of options
and we can mix and match with whatever
we think is best
okay I'm not keen on this I don't think
we've done this elsewhere and I'm not
keen on this sure I think thank you you
can you speak up upon on these also the
biggest thing the bottom is that that
parent of foods which in most cases
doesn't seem to be needed right okay
foods is footer
it's kind of interesting but as soon as
you've got food tight you kind of know
it's a food can't you lead with the food
and then parental type that's really the
parent is the cookie in this case yeah
but apparently that's a food type yeah
but it's like cookie paren food type or
something as opposed to food type cookie
yeah there is a version where we use a
comment instead I think it's one of the
next you yeah in fact it's the next one
error I'm sorry this is a little bit
different there is another one that has
the comment mom the food type are there
I think it's the Model S emphasis on the
property one
this one isn't terrible I think
yeah you just need to bold that first
item right the food types should be
stronger than the subordinate pieces are
you sure I think so yeah I chicken you
know way bigger than well least bold
compared to fried and leg yeah bolding
is not something that I had taken into
account but yeah we can definitely do
that I'm not keen on this
that's interesting
Michael do you want to comment on this
no not really
do you like it do not like it Android I
looked at many of them and your head is
now spinning cause you look too too many
no I think and I like the one that at
least computer Li most the most kinda
inlined which isn't our own style I
don't think it's gonna work I think that
we don't have enough energy to make that
work
okay I mean this isn't terrible okay
this is the common one that I was during
- I'm not buying this I don't think this
works I think it works in these examples
I think it's really weird chicken fried
leg but could the first item be like you
know as displayed but you can go back to
the way we had it before with the others
they're just like chicken food type as
the parent I'm not certain that's gonna
work in all cases well guys what happens
there is it true that that one is is
really the the main event I have a bad
feeling it's not I don't think I
understand the question well the
question is this food type if you only
saw one thing and you saw food type
would it always be sensible to go what
I'm saying or is that cases where the
food type is way too generic and where a
common person just saying what are you
eating
okay if the question is what are you
eating and the answer is the first thing
you say is the food type then that's one
thing if the first thing you say if the
food type is meat let's say it's
unlikely you would say that you would
say I'm eating chicken sandwich whatever
get what I'm saying
the food type is always a reason to the
specific thing okay so if you're if
you're suggesting getting rid of the
food type label by beefer and I think
that makes sense because most of the
time you should be able to pick out that
it is a food type not even thing that I
just that that rendering of that first
you know no Jeremy is suggesting that
the chicken pot is rendered that way and
then it says preparation fried yeah yes
oh oh I see yeah yeah I I'd be okay with
that I think that sounds like a good
idea
are you in a position to try it in real
time here or is this to code too
complicated to try to do that see no no
wait a minute wait a minute so no this
is exactly what I was afraid of look at
this case here that's where that's where
it falls apart
and named floated to the top yeah but
then then you're going to be
inconsistent and say you know the now
it's not the food type now it's the pop
top I don't think it's a good idea I
think these the um I mean I mean we can
reorder these things - no I I understand
that but we don't want to do that
because we don't want that's exactly the
concern that I had right that food type
is gonna be pastry right which is not
useful you're saying what are you eating
I'm eating pastry no you said I'm eating
a pop-tart I hate those things but
that's different this year um yeah I
mean it's same thing here I mean this is
nice that the brand name comes first
yeah someone in our life
aptly handled corn-on-the-cob asks
whether it makes sense for the
preparation to come first unfortunately
not because these while in English the
preparation might often come first it is
there's no guarantee that actually that
the actual words make sense that way
around
that a fair statement Andrew etc yes the
order is a little complicated yeah
alright let's just take a look at this
okay that's a different issue what would
he be doing this yeah oh well that's a
different issue that's the issue of
comparisons right yes right and one of
the things that I noticed in trying some
of the stuff particularly in the more
boxy versions that take up a lot more
space when you get the separator forum
with the alternatives bar between things
it gets a little difficult to see them
because they're always on the right with
this at least on my you can see that the
comparison is happening over used versus
anywhere else right it was more a
suggestion and an idea to maybe spark an
idea you know well what do you Michael
what do you think yeah Android I I think
it's nicely parley us yes that I agree
with I mean this plus is we first had a
plus at the end of the line where you
think it's a mistake I think it's going
to be a line breaking thing it has to be
at the beginning of the line I think
yeah not what we do for forum like a
nice
let's get some nice pluses wow it's at
the end of the line but it's always
through mathematics we always put at the
end of the bet it's part of the reason
why I wanted to set this up in a column
format like this because it's sometimes
gets lost I think you're right that I'd
like it to be on the left mob but that's
not the default behavior hmm okay um
okay what is this total prefix so now
the properties say total and then the
insides have the usual formatting or
something else so before it would just
say calorie content but now it says
total calorie content it's an idea I
don't think we need that if the pluses
makes sense yeah if we want to do the
pluses then yeah you want them in the
column like that I don't know but but
but I mean are you saying what are we
doing now we've got vertical bars right
now yes that's the default behavior even
if you say total calorie content then
those vertical bars are replaced with
pluses but they would more or less
format the same way but that's that's
the case right now so I mean the
question is
little confused here is this well many
of these are quite ugly yeah I mean this
isn't working
you're right this isn't working for
these heavily stack things that's just
hopeless make sense why isn't it the
case instead of a versus when should
just leave a space here well yeah I
think that yeah we can do that I mean I
don't know Jeremy do used to have
thought about that well I think it maybe
just invert a horizontal line right
separate the box yes that would be
reasonable I think that'd be fine it's
clear they're separate at that point
because it is a versus case yeah yeah I
mean so in other words a very light yeah
just a gray line all the way across
connected I think I have one further
down in the notebook but it's not
connected it was just an idea I was
trying to do stuff with we can connect
it I think I sure I think it's better
not connected sure we can do that but
but I mean Jeremy something is wrong
with this I mean needs more space or
something yeah definitely more space and
you have to careful about looking like
division or something you know with two
items but that's where the you know if
it's connected it too clearly part of
that box structure yeah maybe it would
look less busy with it connected what do
you think yeah yeah I think I look
better connected Dossett lines maybe I
don't know what that would mean no look
I think just like the frame would be the
cleanest okay I don't see what total
does for us here well the if we like
those bars so much the idea would be
then we would do it for both the
comparison and total case or the
addition case I think the third is
usually because like if you wouldn't if
you just would see the right you
wouldn't know if you want to compare our
it I understand but don't isn't that
don't we have a currently a form where
we are saying if it's blah plus blah I
mean if it's blah plus blur it should be
written differently and represented
differently from the compare
in case and I think A+ is a fine thing
and I think plus in the vertical case
you know vertical plus is I mean I think
that's quite decent I know Jeremy what
do you think about that for the total
case yeah I think it looks fine
that means you wouldn't use the word
total on the Left I don't think so yeah
because this is the thing you're talking
about is that Plus that yeah I agree
yeah I don't think we should probably
mix the total and the vertical plus
thing yeah too much yeah yeah so I don't
I think this is a fine solution here now
is there anything that we could have
here Jeremy that doesn't isn't a line
all across the pay the way up the wall
the way across the page for example I
don't know a grey dot or something there
or something to indicate that these are
separated items but without having to
have the busyness of a whole extra thing
I don't think it'd take a dedicated Rose
just fine it added the visual space and
it you know separates them could you
could you take this and try and
photoshop it or something yeah um okay
you were hoping to close it up a little
bit yeah relative to this I think hmm I
don't know but not too far because
otherwise it's gonna get way confusing
yeah I don't think it's that bad
actually with that plus just removed
wait a minute what what case is
I think the I thought you said the plus
days for the no no no I'm saying I'm
saying the case where the foods are
added the plus days yeah okay
yes okay I'll Bob compare the two cases
then okay so the next question is if we
if we believe in this
now the hundred grams of I think it's
just too crowded what's that an
additional level of boxing the hundred
calm eating the right hand side is just
too much at least for me sorry sorry so
there again what like if the hundred
calm would generate and spin of a box
that would kept the food to the right I
feel like it's getting too crowded
worried what do you say what what box
what which box were if the hundred come
would would be tender the left hand side
of a box that the right hand side of the
box ace of what it's too much I like
this one much better I wasn't I don't
know what was being proposed else well
and I'm just are you saying um think
he's saying instead of using 100 grams
of whatever the box structure is on the
right um in the past we've tried to do
things where we had another box
structure for does that held the
quantity and the food in one shot I
don't think that's the only possibility
which you had someplace here is the
amount in its own little box attached do
you have that uh that's a good question
I think it's a mountaintop Jay and I
rather like this because sometimes the
amount one item is kind of an irrelevant
thing but sometimes the amount you know
I like this
rather than saying 100 grams of because
sometimes you know one item or is very
stupid for instance well I mean it just
it looks silly to say one item of a
little it's one peach one item of food
type peach but but one watermelon is
very another one you'll see never do you
want to know this what do you mean like
most you are interested in foods in a
amount you typically eat so any foods
that are big you don't want that item I
understand but a peach you eat in one
sitting
yes big yeah yeah and then saying
inserting so normally you'd say one
peach but if you have to say one item of
peach yes you're right that that's sound
we have to say one item a peach in the
lower ones I guess we do what would what
does the framework actually support for
peaches I don't think I know how to
answer that question well is it going to
say one item of peach or is it going to
say one peach we can make it say one
peach at the moment the code that I used
to make these things probably not but it
can be done I wonder if it can be done
consistently I see and we've had some
pretty good luck with this stuff for
spoken results things we have some
pretty good data on when to use it and
we're not so I'm pretty confident that
we can do that so what would you imagine
putting let's say it was the the you
know one peach where would you put that
I mean one peach preparation I know what
you do to peaches
yeah yeah it's it's a little bit
unconventional so for the website this
very careful distinction between the
various qualifiers is actually not so
other one that's mostly for the language
where we have to be precise so and
Android I discussed a flavor of this
what about we when we have the case of
one be kind of fold the one into the
food type even if this isn't quite
correct and kinda depending even a
little bit they find peach Apple we
would find a whole
or something like this it's not gonna
work because look at the case of the
pop-tart right the food type there is
pastry which arguably should be
suppressed because it's kind of
irrelevant and silly right right so
whereas I had one pastry you the truth
enormous ink at least I use this
language do you have to eat pop-tarts no
I'm essentially certain that somebody
would say I have one pop-tart not I have
one pastry and it was a pop-tart
I see yeah I agree yes the problem is
that then then the other problem is that
with these brands it might be you know
green giant corn or something
right and the brand is sort of
irrelevant in that case see what I'm
saying there might be some way to detect
the case where in in parsing when only
the brand name is used and then we could
format that differently presumably when
it is possible to use only the bound
lame like an Oreo right suppose to
cookie or if brand type Oreo yeah or
even Oreo cookie yeah if if the user put
in Oreo cookie for example then we
probably wouldn't ma just say one Oreo
in the input interpretation perhaps
that's an idea okay so wait a minute so
you're identifying those things which
are under brandable so to speak right so
some things like I mean there are some
pretty marginal cases like for example a
I don't know an ice cream bar is it a
hug and das ice cream bar a dove ice
cream bar do you care see what I'm
saying so I mean I know that they try to
make it you know dove bar is supposed to
be a thing or in chocolate for example
you know have a you know a Cadbury
something I mean they tried to make that
a thing but I think most people would
just say a bar of chocolate right but
there are cases like KitKat for example
where people would
yeah when you will only call it that and
I have no idea what the generic name is
yeah I've I don't know either but but
the point is is in those cases that
where we parse it using only the brand
name we could do something different so
that it would say one Oreo one KitKat I
know but I'm giving you the case where
I'm sure we can parse one dove bar see
what I'm saying yes many people that
would be um that will be purely a
Germany's then yeah um has internal
taking forever to connect um okay but
but um that right so I mean the issue
here is take the Dove bar case okay is
this dove bar or is it an ice cream you
know is it a chocolate wherever they are
you know is it something that will be
named more generically that's it that's
a case where you know whatever the
company might like or not like you know
people have a common way of talking
about it whereas for instance let's say
what about some it's a good example that
there are cases where there is a brand
name version and then there's a generic
right but I think this would be more on
how the user punches it in so to speak
if the user refers to it as a single
thing without the food attached to it
then we would treat it the same way they
do but if you if you said it in the more
generic terms announced legalization I
mean we have to canonicalize it it's no
good if we look at the point about a
KitKat for example is that in a first
approximation there isn't something
directly like that that you know if
you're gonna get a thing like that it's
you know what I don't know layers of
chocolate and whatever they are but but
in the entity world canonicalization a
different step you can have the same
implicit entity class that you described
differently and this entity list you can
only
you don't immediately canonicalize fair
enough okay so what are you guys
suggesting you're suggesting that we try
harder to break out something that could
be called food I mean the limiting case
is that the whole thing is you know
natural language generated and it just
becomes one fried chicken leg right yeah
in the ideal case yeah and I this is the
ideal case I'm not sure it's the ideal
case I mean that's all well and good
when it's as simple as that but if it
gets more complicated you know when
there's a stack of seven or eight of
these qualifiers taking apart the
English statement is complicated and
it's actually easier to have it stacked
like that and to identify what the what
the elements are I mean I don't know how
deep these stacks typically get or can
get but you know it reminds me of the
typical restaurant menu where you know
it could just be a hamburger and fries
or the restaurant is very you know
elaborate and has this thing that's two
lines long describing the the wonders of
the you know you know free-range
grass-fed blah-blah-blah-blah-blah thing
and by the time you've got all those
qualifiers of free-range grass-fed
whatever that's a big complicated stack
and reading it off in English is not
actually as easy as you might think did
that make sense yeah yeah I agree
um it's actually an advantage to have it
in structured form yeah I mean III you
know I have to say this does not bother
me a mount you know food type
preparation food but I mean this is
pretty easy to read if you if you think
you know what this is you just read down
the right-hand side chicken-fried leg
okay fine I know what that is
but if you're confused you can look at
the left-hand side
yeah I don't know what this means here
food type and added food what does added
food mean oh I see it's a cookie with
chocolate chips oh my gosh and that can
happen all over the place right yeah
yeah I'm telling you the only thing we
can count on being able to do is the
structured stuff because that's what
we've built anything else is kind of a
fake hey Keith
hey Keith I mean we've obviously we can
do it in a bunch of cases for spoken
results but that's you know we have to
do it carefully and it is less yeah so I
mean I guess I'm favoring this kind of
stack is there a reason why we want to
separate out the amount from the other
stuff I personally am NOT a big fan of
this the one peach theory so to speak so
what I know but what would be your
proposal how to give is it amount one
item food type peach that's it that's a
one peach okay
Peach's amount three items for this what
side now in the screen I know I know I'm
agreeing with that I'm saying don't try
to make it more language joking okay
yeah and then the pop-tart case would be
the same way there is the pop-tart case
would probably be like that that's great
that's great amount brand-name food talk
I mean I think the case that is a little
bit trickier which you maybe should show
is something which is a generic but we
have the branded version of the generic
am I making sense I think so but I think
it's okay because we use the order in
which things were parsed so if you said
my thinking you said to pop tart
pastries I think it would still show up
well let me come up as if if what you do
and this will be mostly chosen for an
input interpretation if you say and I'm
no expert on food so that you buying
grocery stores but I think there's a a
like you you know like peas or something
right frozen peas i I think you know
like green giant frozen peas or birds
I've that exist or is that a British
brand that went out of business fifty
years ago I have no idea but you know
bird's-eye peas or something versus
Green Giant Peas
mm-hm right it is actually not that
important to most users which brand
those are right and and I think it's the
current state of how it works would be
the opposite order you see here because
pop-tarts was used instead it would be
amount whatever food type whatever grant
whatever fine gets that order and I
think that's what you want right yeah
that's exactly what all months it's just
good on you okay so now next question
should it be gray left-hand side and so
on like this or should it be like one of
your white versions where's the white
version where's the version where it was
where it's named but less emphasis on
properties that the one I think so
yeah that's the one without the gray
Jeremy do you have an opinion here I
kind of like this version yeah me too
they've been just slightly lighter on
the left but yeah definitely that's what
I think that's what you're doing here
yeah just from here it's fairly low
contrast between the two oh yeah you're
suggesting more contrast yeah just a
little bit fair enough okay I added the
link to for maybe separating out the
amount well but in chat yeah and there's
a new link but but let's take a look at
this example that you've done here okay
well this is gonna look a heck a lot
better without those hundred grand
things hanging off the left mm-hmm but I
think we need to look at what it looks
like if you just have a plus without um
you know between those things okay
you've got a new idea here it's probably
no stacks it's nice to separate out the
amount I do agree yeah it's a different
type than the other eye that's nice
I agree yeah looks good okay let's see
what it looks like with with tall stacks
with pluses vertically I think it's not
going to look good okay I have another
idea so we decided that we don't want to
total when we sum it up what about the
reverse if we want to compare we say
comparison somehow in the left that
makes it totally clear but what's on the
right I mean how do you have the
multiple things on the right in some
flavor as Jeremy showed with some kind
of dividers it doesn't matter anymore
because it's obvious there's something
to be compared I think I have an example
of that if you scroll further in the
notebook I don't remember which letter
or anything but I do have variant
similar to that I think it has like a
car column header should be it's under
the new attempts for certain
food type is header no that's that's not
quite it I'll take a look in my cup its
case P should be the last one in that
alphabet yes I knew I was getting close
to the end okay yeah I don't like this I
was thinking down the left like we could
move it on on the left but the idea is
the same here I think sugar content
comparison exactly or compare sugar
content maybe would that be better so
different from what we're doing else
well yes okay so listen but the main
problem is indicating things then Jeremy
I was not a huge fan I mean maybe you
could take something more like these
stacks that we have and with without the
gray and so on if you can get one of
those and I'm not a huge fan of this
thing that's gonna end up being hugely
you know tall vertically on the page of
you know these different you know
elements that we're combining and then
we've got this giant blob of gray on the
left
spanning that whole region it's kind of
weird I mean I see yeah go ahead
I also don't like it visually but it
makes it very clear that it spans fine
okay okay my question okay the question
is if we are adding the things together
what's the way to indicate that so I'm
not a huge fan of the separator lines
but I'm also don't think the pluses are
gonna work at all when there's and also
I want to know what happens if there are
multiple boxes which have different
widths are they left aligned are they
right are they centered what was
happening to them I think in any
examples that I've done I've centered
them
we could Bluff the line the more right
align them well doctor do you mean you
align them on the on the separator line
which is probably what should happen if
we're gonna do that yeah I I didn't get
into that kind of detail in in the code
I wrote to do this stuff but I I think
that's possible I don't know stop my
head it could potentially leave a lot of
empty space in this box an area on the
right I wouldn't vary too much because
often the things that you would compare
or at you would have approximately the
same specification yeah I don't see too
many things that are much longer than
like what you see towards the top of
your screen now with Granny Smith I
think really you get a handful of words
but probably no more than for most the
time so I don't think things will get to
know what about the possibility of
actually running them sequentially with
line breaking effectively I mean these
things aren't working but I think it's
gonna work a lot better when they're
more integrated like this we try that
okay I think you can look at towards the
top of the notebook one of the later
attempts sort of emulates that I think
it's the current behavior and B I think
is is closer to what you're asking for I
think obviously they're not in boxes
they're in their own little strings with
parentheses after them but that's closer
to what what I think you're suggesting
right yeah but not as vertical these are
these are very horizontal mr. right is
that is that what you were no I was
saying take things like this okay and
have them be like elements in running
text so blah blah plus blah oh so I
chain them with row more or less yes
gotcha
yes yeah that that could work the the
downside is that I think you'd run into
cases like what you have there on your
screen now where the vertical bar is on
the right so like in that protein
tonight because I'm not sure I you know
but it doesn't help that's so little
vertical space here that I don't know
how to control but yeah we could do that
okay so I think the choices are
it's like row like behavior with pluses
in between or something like vertical
bars and the vertical bars could span
vertically which would certainly help um
or everything is in a vertical stack
those seem to me to be the obvious
choices I think with respect to what's
happening with these boxes I think we're
more or less straight on that this is
also the case where we have what you
have seemed a shortage chip cookie so
there's a half chocolate chip all of us
all Grayson's computers all raisins you
know would be well so what does that
look like it's not in the case you can
we see what it looks like I mean so so
are you saying that there's a without
case or something it's it's possible to
do in energy value at the moment we have
how do we format it that's a question
that still has to be open which were we
haven't really looked into too much yet
wait a sec wasn't was it was it so this
is an exclusion of something in the food
is that correct
yes it's something without something
right so this is a cookie why shouldn't
this be called additions rather than
added food I mean it might not be a food
it's a chocolate chip which is hardly
what when we call and why don't we just
say whatever you eat is a food fine
so we so you don't it's kind of
redundant to say that Hill couldn't it
just be called addition I mean I guess
we can yeah or additions
edits I feel I guess Beloff added well I
find addition strange here what about
addition well it is and what is being
said there is an addition
chocolate chip of course it's
generically chocolate chips plural
because there's not just one chocolate
chip in the cookie one hopes but but
what I mean is it's not you have one
food and you put another food on top
that I would call addition that's kind
of baked in with yeah we there's
certainly an obvious thing
yeah which seems okay the thing I worry
about is um if you look at the left-hand
column then with doesn't really fit in
yes like food type makes any sense
with seems like a strange word to use
there but I agree it could be it needs
to be a noun
which is why I suggested addition right
the addition probably isn't right
another idea that we could do is in the
added foods case instead of making it a
separate row we could have cookie with
being in gray and then after that have
chocolate chip to the right of it so it
would be food expense I mean yeah I
understand what you're saying
might be but it's not a reasonable thing
to do in general I thought I don't know
it was just an idea I was just you know
we have to inventory what possible added
food there is there it could be any food
so I mean it could be a cookie with
bananas yep
then I think it's better to stack it
okay what the heck can we call that
though ingredient it's not quite
technically not an ingredient yeah it's
a dessert I almost want to say additive
but that means completely Dane's but
contains not really known
corn on the cob on the livestream is is
asking whether what does the industry
use for these things Andrew but is there
an industry name for such a thing I
don't think so
mica you're a little more close with
this stuff than I am right but the point
is that an additive people know what a
food additive is and it's not usually a
good thing it's almost like an extra
ingredient yeah look I mean the problem
is it can't just be you know a
preposition like with blah blah blah it
should be a noun but for now let's say
added food I added element added of it's
pretty weird element sounds very
scientific and it's you know an added
element of a chocolate chip is really
weird added element of whipped cream see
added food whipped cream is going to be
really bad to read as well but that
supplement no looks like it's like
taking your you know vitamin D it really
is you know fortified cereal or
something
I'm not sure okay added food for now
let's try to solve the case if you have
no without raisins yeah we're talking
about that without raisins case then you
could have remand
yeah it could be move sent food I mean
it's like okay listen listen look
clearly with and without would work if
edit is there then absence is not for
the hey I am I'm agreeing but I think
they're both kind of cruddy so let's try
the possibility of with yeah I like that
American news without for the absent
case right I think I'm I think the Wis
although it is a little bit different in
that column I think it's still clear
what that means but I mean maybe this
could be a little bit kale less gray you
mean because if it says without it's
really important that it's yes I mean
they're any less yes I do mean grass
blacker yeah right now that makes sense
that makes sense
let's let's try that okay so the
remaining thing we have to solve in the
no time we have available is what to do
with multiple elements here and whether
to put the pluses Jeremy did you mark
anything up by no chance
yeah you could go back to my design
folder you can do food compared to you
click that first link okay
just to to right at the yeah yeah you'd
have to do some calculation on pod width
to figure out how to make this work and
in that comparison case with the you
basically have a grid that you have to
parse what the layouts gonna be sounds
complicated but I guess it could be done
I think that's not right I don't like it
for the following reasons like that the
lowest one it is not clear to me if you
compare three or the some of the first
to Vista silt hmm it's also a little
weird without the pluses hanging at the
beginning of the line here what does it
look like if they're stacked vertically
I think the plus in a vertical stack is
going to look really weird
comments it quickly replaced by a small
gray end
I don't think that's gonna help I mean
then we got to have a similar thing for
the for the other case how would you
feel about this case if there weren't
any separated lines here I mean also
this is a somewhat exceptional case
because these are the same height yeah
one lady would be to force off the
pluses on the left side um and do it in
this way so if you know that it's gonna
span the width so maybe the top two and
like in the second case you could have
one box plus another immediately to its
right and then basically the example
that's there take the plus sign moving
on to the left of the line below and
then have it that way because it would
stretch across but the pluses would
always be forced on the left I'm
skeptical whenever there's a new line
I'm skeptical I think these cases okay
so look what I think we need to do is
you should generate some cases where
there are random different heights and
so on here okay Heights and widths and
humph I just think it's gonna get
incredibly tall if we stack them
completely you should also not over
engineer in the sense of this very
highly qualified foods and then mood to
be compared of them is a rare event in
decree streams yeah fair enough
well so are you arguing that we should
just try and stack them yeah exactly
oh yes it's not pretty but in this hair
cases it's clear and okay you have just
called one time or on your food um
somehow live stream is saying this
browser window is only half on screen
cutoff right now I don't think so that's
a that's a problem for the folks
worrying about the live streaming
technology um it shouldn't be something
is wrong um okay so okay again last
thing the plus where does it go
maybe the plus is gray and centered on
the line here
mm-hmm and then we hope this what sir I
like this okay but that means it's gonna
out dent some of these things are gonna
out dent correct okay
all right do we think we have a solution
here seems like it I would call it a
piece of losin but we have we have once
it falls off okay fine all right well so
and we will go off and implement this
then we'll we'll take a look at a bunch
of examples okay thank you all very much
and thanks to folks on the livestream we
were back in about an hour for a meeting
about geometry and the definition of
angles um okay
see y'all soon